is the universe of alien civilizations
defined by war
as much
or more
than uh
war defined human history
i would say it's defined by competition
and then the question is how much
competition
implies war
so
uh up until recently competition defined
life on earth yes
competition between species and
organisms and among humans competitions
among individuals and communities and
that competition often took the form of
war in the last 10 000 years
many people now are hoping or even
expecting to sort of suppress and end
competition in human affairs
uh they regulate business competition
they prevent military competition
and
that's a future i think a lot of people
will like to continue and strengthen
people will like to have something close
to world government or world governance
or at least a world community and they
will like to suppress war and many forms
of business and personal competition
over the coming centuries
and
they may like that so much that they
prevent interstellar colonization which
would become the end of that era that is
interstellar colonization would just
return
severe competition to human or our
descendant affairs and many
civilizations may prefer that and ours
may prefer that but if they choose to
allow interstellar colonization
they will have chosen to allow
competition to return with great force
that is there's really not much of a way
to centrally govern a rapidly expanding
sphere of civilization and so i think
the one of the most
you know solid things we can predict
about gravians is they have accepted
competition
and they have internal competition and
therefore
they have the potential for competition
when they meet each other at the borders
but whether that's military competition
is more of an open question so military
meaning
physically destructive right
um
[Music]
so there's a lot to say there so one
idea that you kind of proposed
is
progress might be maximized through
competition
through some kind of healthy competition
some definition of healthy so like
constructive not destructive competition
so like we would likely
grabby alien civilizations would be
likely defined by competition because
they can expand faster because they
competition allows
innovation and sort of the battle of
ideas the way i would take the logic is
to say you know competition just
happens if you can't coordinate to stop
it
and you probably can't coordinate to
stop it in an expanding interstellar
wave so competition is a
fundamental force
in the universe it has been so far and
it
would be within an expanding grabby
alien civilization but we today have the
chance many people think and hope of
greatly controlling and limiting
competition within our civilization for
a while
and that's an interesting choice
whether to allow competition to re
to sort of regain its full force
or whether to suppress and manage it
well one of the open questions
that has been raised
in the past um
less than 100 years
is whether our desire
to lessen the destructive nature of
competition
or the destructive kind of competition
will be outpaced by the destructive
power of our weapons
sort of uh
if
nuclear weapons and weapons of that kind
become more destructive than our desire
for peace
then it all it takes is one [ __ ] at
the party
to ruin the party it takes one [ __ ]
to make a delay but not that much of a
delay on the cosmological scales we're
talking about so you could even party on
even a vast nuclear war if it happened
here right now on earth
it would not kill all humans yes
it certainly wouldn't kill all life
and so human civilization would return
within 100 000 years
so all
the history of atrocities
and
um if you look at uh
uh the
the black plague right
which is
not human cause atrocities or whatever
there are a lot of military
atrocities in history absolutely in the
20th century those are
um
those challenges
to think about human nature but the
cosmic scale of time and space
they do not stop the human spirit
essentially
the humanity goes on
through all the atrocities it goes on
like most likely so even a nuclear war
isn't enough to destroy us
or to stop our potential from expanding
but
we could institute a
regime of global governance that limited
competition including military and
business competition of sorts and that
could prevent our expansion
you